but uh someone said in the chat earlier
which maybe kind of what i want to talk
about more today is the um i don't know
it feels like the lore has sort of run
dry
does anyone else feel that way the lore
in the game is kind of run dry we're all
just like making random ass theories and
that's pretty much it it's because they
didn't write any lore
dude i am telling you i don't think they
finished the lore and they did it on
purpose is that too far of a stretch to
say here i don't think they finished
writing anything because they didn't
need to because they knew the community
would just like come up with random crap
are we just writing the dlc for them
they're like oh that's a cool idea let's
let's make that into dlc what's your
favorite from software game i
i don't think it's this one i like eldon
ring because it's a fantastic open world
game and i really wasn't even a fan of
open world games before elden ring but i
don't i don't think it's this one this
game has a lot of cool stuff going on
like i absolutely like love how refined
it is based on every other
game out there i think i do want to talk
about this topic today with you guys and
i'm curious what you guys think do you
all think
that the biggest issue with eldon ring
is that the game is too big and also to
answer your question i would say my
favorite from software game
is dark souls 3. i have 1500 hours in
dark souls 3. hell no yes kind of sorta
i want it bigger
yeah it's sort of like a kinda right
because that was the main appeal in cell
to the game it was this is big dark
souls it's it's really if you want to
describe elden ring
in a very
basic way it's big dark souls and that's
totally fine but
the game is so large that at least for
me and press one in chat if you agree
with me the game is so big and there's
so many kind of tedious things that i
have to do to make my character somewhat
strong
by gathering smithing stones or going
way out somewhere to get an item or a
weapon or whatever
it's too much of a hassle to do that so
i just don't want to do that at least
starting a new character like new game
plus runs are fun for a while
and then you get to new i think it's new
game plus seven i might be wrong on that
i think it's new game plus seven where
all the difficulty just kind of plateaus
it's gonna be as hard as it gets um your
character is obviously gonna be
extremely strong and just keep playing
through the game with like the character
that you build or whatever but then
after that there's like really no point
to it there's almost no direction
i don't think there needs to be
direction i'm gonna sit on the throne
right in front of his face
never mind yeah screw direction i don't
play elden ring to have direction
because i think elden ring is the best
open world game that there ever has been
i don't think you can make an open world
game better than they made this one in
my opinion i know there's tons of
balancing issues you know reused bosses
all over the place but i love
the fact that they don't give me a quest
marker on the map and tell me where to
go that's so awesome the big issue with
that though and i think the big issue
with elden ring in general is that you
only get that experience
one time that
sense of no direction
and that sense of discovery you're
you're going around an open world and
you're seeing everything for the first
time and it is literally the best gaming
experience that anybody can have i in my
opinion is the first playthrough of this
game maybe even the second playthrough
just because in a second playthrough
at least for me there was plenty of
stuff that i missed
i completely missed melania my first
playthrough i had to get her a new game
plus one
no idea where she was never saw her but
i saw her in the trailer and i'm like
where where is this red haired chick
like where did she go dude never saw the
flame of frenzy i never went that deep
in the sewers didn't know how to get
there got lost in the sewers gave up
went away so you only get that
experience that open world sense of
discovery experience one time maybe two
playing the game for the second or third
time like we were
just talking about
where
some things feel tedious that's just
because you know where those tedious
things are because our first and second
playthrough we didn't know what was
tedious or not i can tell you all i've
i've 100 of the game we did it all on
stream we did every single thing this
game had to offer and i could tell you
there are plenty of dungeons that i will
never go back to because it is just not
worth it it's boring i didn't like that
dungeon
i don't like the item you get at the end
of the dungeon i don't like the boss at
the end of not just that dungeon but
maybe just an area in general
there are areas that i will quite
literally just never go back to i don't
know if you guys are like me this forest
right here
never been back and i don't know why i
just avoid that area completely there's
not a lot in here besides the one uh
castle that becomes invisible and you
have to unlock it and then the worm face
boss and that's kind of really it yeah
this right here i think it disappears if
i get too close
yep there we go it's gone but the first
time i played this game
the first my first playthrough when i
saw that
i was like whoa
that's so cool right but just as i just
showed you i'm coming up here and i'm
like oh i already know it's doing it
disappear i have to do this tedious
puzzle
that i already know the locations of to
open up the castle okay so you guys are
saying well the worm phase drops
something good you're right
but how much goes into even getting into
this area after your first playthrough
you have to find either
the dectus medallions one and two which
one is in the lower part where where is
it like the missed wood it's in that
castle where kenneth hyde is and then
the other one is in kaelin in the fort
you get both of those then you can take
the deck this lift and then you can
become you can get to all this plateau
and then you can technically get here
right or you can go through the mines
which
how long does it take for you to ride
there like let's say you get torrent in
your next playthrough you have to see
melania at wherever you get her the gate
front or whatever and then you have to
ride you can totally skip the castle you
can go this way you can go the side you
have to go all the way through the lake
and and mind you this is just a straight
shot you are just going to the mines to
just get to ulta's plateau to get
whatever item you like in this area
that's going to take you so much time
and then you're gonna get here way
before you want to you're not gonna have
an like you're not if you get in any
fight you're gonna die so then you have
to go get like smithing stones i find it
so annoying to collect regular smithing
stones so that i can upgrade one of my
weapons i don't are you guys like that
as well i would rather collect sombers
they're much easier to get
you know we have to get the altus
plateau to advance the game anyway right
i know where all of those good minds are
as well so i just bee line it right to
those but the entire point of why i'm
talking about that
is because you're just beelining at that
point you're like i know where those
good
somber smithing stones are i know where
those good smithing stones like mass
quantities of them i know where those
dungeons are and you beeline it right to
those areas just to get the upgrades i
feel like normal enemies don't drop
enough runes
you pretty much have to kill main bosses
to get enough runes
to be able to upgrade those weapons and
your character to be able to even be
able to use those weapons that you want
stat requirements are too high
yeah i'm not sure but right the the main
point of me talking about all of this
stuff is that it makes me
not want to play the game again it isn't
it like 90
95 of the player base
just stop playing elden ring is too big
i've never had that feeling in like dark
souls 3 or dark souls 1
where
i say to myself i don't want to play it
because it's just too much when this
game is totally like marketed
not marketed
but there's obviously a lot of
replayability in this game you have so
many different like classes
weapons
all kinds of different things to do in
this game
but so many people were just like no i'm
gonna do my one
uh and then i'm done
and even i somebody who makes content
for this game as a job have that same
feeling where it's like i don't want to
play through the game again so i have to
do all kinds of like creative things to
keep me like wanting to play the game
there's two little main bosses in the
game
radon
melania
ranala
moog
i mean we fight morgot three times
basically fire giant godric yeah god
free twice right card of course sorry
placa dew sacks for the sax
yeah the godskins we fight a lot but
then there's like 160 something total
bosses i would say that's probably as
many memorable bosses as there are in
dark souls 3. yeah ratagon is an amazing
fight but i
cannot stand the elden beast i've never
had this much of a of an issue
trying to understand
a souls game
and it's lore like i totally understand
bloodborne and i totally understand dark
souls
sekiro is so straightforward even the
way they tell this game it's so
is straightforward there's so much
happening which goes into more of what
we were talking about earlier that this
game is too big it's so hard to put
everything together and like you just
said handyman i think we just have to be
patient
and wait
or dlc do you guys think
yes or no
that dlc for elden ring will come out in
2022 this year okay a lot of you guys
are saying no
totally agree
i don't know how they could how how long
do you think a dlc in comparison to
elden ring the game itself that probably
took us hundreds of hours each to beat
maybe not that much like at least 50
hours to beat the game at least 50
probably closer to 100 in between there
somewhere to beat the game how long do
you think a dlc has to be to even
warrant it i mean are they just gonna
make an entirely new area
or are they gonna put it somewhere out
here because at least to me
i see
the dlc
like changing the landscape kind of like
how we did when we beat radon
uh there's a point where speculation
turns from fun into frustration i think
eldon ring left up too much to
speculation i think more answers would
have been better
i agree but
did did we really expect from software
to tell us a story that made sense
from the get-go hell no do you think
you'll cover other games once elven ring
starts to slow down significantly
i'm not sure for now we're just doing
elden ring because there's really no
point in doing anything else i would
like to though i would absolutely love
that
but for now no